willkommen zur heutigen sitzung der
letzten sitzungen die wir wirklich
thematisch uns ein vornehmen ein thema
vorgenommen haben
dieser sitzung geht es jetzt um den
begriff der liebe wieder diesmal aber
bei harry frankfurt einen neueren noch
lebenden denker zu dem ich gleich auch
noch ein bisschen was genau das sagen
werde hier wieder der seminarplan in der
letzten sitzung hatten wir den begriff
der liebe diskutiert bei augustinus
genauer gesagt bei einer ahrens
interpretation von augustins liebes
begriff heute geht es jetzt um herr in
frankfurt einen noch lebenden denker und
seine auffassung von liebe die ich sehr
interessant finde
und in der letzten sitzung der letzten
nächsten woche werden wir dann die
ganzen behandelten themen emotionen
überblicken zusammenfassen und noch
abschließend diskutieren
das ist jetzt der plan des im haus was
sich langsam aber sicher dem ende
zuneigt jetzt noch ein bisschen
rückblick auf der sitzung das ist
augustinus und das ist seine arendt und
sie hat diese schrift verfasst als die
situation der liebesbrief bei augustin
oben rechts manchen leben zu letzte zu
sein damit sie sich noch mal die
nachschauen könnte interesse ja was
waren wichtige punkte
die liebe haben wir jetzt unabhängig von
augustinus unter einer art diskutiert
darf als eine oppositions emotionen zur
evolution des fasses kelten ganz
interessant nämlich ist der hat mir auch
die liebe als emotionen einen bestimmten
effekt jeweils entgegengesetzt die
gegensatz eben zu emotion
der hass ist der mut den effekt der wut
entgegen gesetzt die wünsche erfüllt uns
noch kurz die hass hingegen trägt ganz
lange kann es auch vielmehr
motivationskraft geben kann es auch
vielmehr die vernunft einschalten lassen
genauso ist in der liebe die liebe muss
dieser effekt der begierde oder
triebhaftigkeit entgegengesetzt werden
sie geht auch nicht im moment auf wie es
der effekt des triebes regierung tut
sondern sie erstreckt sich längere
zeiten könnten auch kultiviert werden
jetzt hat eine art in ihrer dissertation
verschiedene formen im ausdruck von
augustinus unterschieden wir behandeln
jetzt nicht alle
es geht erst mal den begriff des amor
der geht als überbegriff und jetzt
unterscheidet sie die kopie die tat also
das begehren als eine form der liebe die
auf weltliches oder vergängliches
gerichtet ist und eine form der liebe
die auf ewigkeit das unvergängliche
gericht ist und das ist dann die caritas
die man als uneigennütziger liebe
genauer stimmen könnte während das
begehren ihr eine eigennützige form
verliebe ist und auch harry frank wird
auf dem wir jetzt gleich noch näher
eingehen
der hat eigentlich so eine form von
uneigennütziger liebe im blick wenn er
darüber genaue untersuchungen anstellen
aber noch mal kurz zum verhältnis
vergeben und hass sondern sich noch wir
hatten hier diese sehr komplizierte
übersicht erstellt der ersten sitzung
wir müssen weiter diskutieren ob die
tragfähig bühne darauf hinweisen es geht
jetzt hier um die emotion und im affekt
die liebe in hass und sie sehen jetzt
hier
das scheint so oppositionelle effekte zu
sein also zwei analoge effekte seien wie
die liebe zur begierde so der hass zum
effekt der wut und zwar deswegen weil
die emotionen im august sind liebe und
hass und robust sie fliegen nicht
einfach während die begierde und mehr
noch die wut sehr schnell leben
verfliegen kann obwohl sie durchaus
integral uns erfassen ja jetzt kommen
wir zu den leitfragen also erst die
frage lautet worauf kann sich die liebe
nach frankfurt richten also die
internationalität welche funktion
übernimmt die liebe gegenliebe wille und
autonomie zusammen inwiefern werden wir
in der liebe genötigt spricht auch von
einer notwendigkeit
inwiefern besitzt die liebe rationale
effektive und multinationale dimensionen
dazu sagt helfen wird ganz konkret etwas
so sieht der gute mann aus und er hat
ihm einen aufsatz geschrieben so 1994
autonomien das messeteam und für
diejenigen unter ihnen die sich für
seine philosophie insbesondere seine
freiheits theorie mehr interessieren
mich oben rechts und links zu einer
sitzung aus dem vergangenen semester wo
wir seine freiheits theorie genauer
untersucht haben und sein begibt der
liebe steht auch im kontext dieser
freiheits theorie genauer gesagt seine
bilanz theorie ein hochinteressanter
denker der auch ein buch geschrieben hat
in der region bullshit wolfsburg
schütten also eine tätigkeit
unterscheidet vom großen lügen der es
gar nicht nur um die wahrheit geht wer
lügt so frankfurt der interessiert sich
immer noch für die wahrheit möchte ihnen
kann nicht die wahrheit wenn gegen burg
schüttet der schwört sich gar nicht und
die wahlen und deswegen ist nach
frankfurt geschickt viel schlimmer als
die lüge
hochinteressant das buch kann ich auch
empfehlen ist ein ganz kleiner ist im
suhrkamp verlag
so jetzt kommen aber gleich auf ihn zu
sprechen er sagt neben dem was uns
bedingt durch unsere praktischen
interessen unseren ehrgeiz unverzichtbar
ist und neben den vorder und jetzt
kategorisch im namen der pflicht
auferlegt sind gibt es noch
erfordernisse der liebe hat es jetzt auf
englisch genannten assassins of love
hier ist jetzt kant mangel kahns pflicht
immer im hintergrund wenn er von
kategorie spricht man natürlich dass mit
dem kategorischen imperativ das
sittengesetz und die pflicht und auch
kann es theorie die achtung als würde
sich zum beispiel sehr gut lohnen eine
hausarbeit an frankfurts begriff die
liebe mit kants begriffe achtung zu
vergleichen das ist wo es
weil er sich ja beide male und sehr
komplexe emotionen handelt die these ist
jetzt von frankfurt ist die liebe viel
wichtiger ist viel bedeutsamer ist als
man gemeinhin glaubt weil sie eine
verbindlichkeit einer form von
verbindlichkeit ausdrückt das könnte man
mit dieser messe city bezeichnen liebe
unterscheidet sich davon gefühle einer
bestimmten art sitzen die starke
anziehungskraft oder intensives
verlangen oder unwiderstehliches
vergnügen
auch ist es nicht gleichbedeutend mit
irgendeinem urteil oder eine
einschätzung des seinem gegenstand innen
ohne wert und es folgt auch nicht daraus
etwas zu lieben ist völlig verschieden
davon ist besonders anziehend oder
kostbar zu halten die tatsache dass eine
person den wert oder die güte da ist
gegenstand ist erkennt besagt nicht dass
es sich um ihn kümmert ja es hat nicht
einmal das überhaupt ein besonderes
interesse angeht nimmt so das ist jetzt
also eine interessante these frankfurt
sagt jedenfalls das nicht mit einem
urteil unbedingt etwas zu tun haben muss
also das wäre jetzt eine antwort auf
unsere frage die wir gestellt und wird
in der liebe nicht so sehr eine
rationale dimension enthalten ja auch
keine einschätzung warum nicht darauf
werden wir später noch genauer eingehen
nur so viel die grund ist der dass es
sich bei der liebe nicht um ein
rationales vermögen handelt ein
rationales phänomen zu eine willentliche
phänomenen volition armes phänomen
natürlich ist liebe für gewöhnlich mit
verschiedenen staaten gefühlen und
überzeugung und die ihr ausdruck
verleihen sie entscheidung stützen das
wesen der liebe ist jedoch weder
effektiv noch kognitiv es ist volition
ahl dass eine person für etwas sorge
trägt oder dass sie etwas liebt hat
weniger damit zu tun wie die dinge ihre
gefühle bewegen oder damit welche
meinungen zu über sie sondern vielmehr
mit den mehr oder weniger ausgeglichenen
worte dazu
strukturen die ihren referenzen gestalt
verleihen und ihr verhalten leiten und
begrenzt dass eine person liebt trägt
zur bestimmung dessen weil welche
wahlentscheidung sie trifft und welche
handlungen zu tun gestrebt oder nicht
willens ist den menschen oft daheim
gegen ihren was sie bei ihren
wahlentscheidungen ihren antrag gibt
können sie sich auch hinsichtlich dessen
wird schon befinden was sie lieben also
hier ist der kernsatz das wesen der
liebe ist weder effektiv noch kognitiv
es ist volition ahl also unsere frage
bezogen
liebe hat nach ihm keine effektive
dimension keine kognitive dimension so
nur eine motivation aldi messe und
könnte man das sagt die auf den willen
bezogen
das ist so die these von ihm dieses
jedoch nicht immer so und auf jeden fall
ist es kein definitions merkmale lieben
dass ihr kreis als kalt sein musste
gegensteuer liebe ist im allgemeinen ein
besonderes konkretes einzelwesen zum
beispiel eine andere person oder ein
land oder eine institution die geliebte
gegenstand kann auch ein objekt
abstrakte rat sei ein moralisches oder
nicht nur alles ist ideal zb ist der
gegenstand der liebe ein einzelnes zu
mögen sich oftmals eine stärke emotionen
und dringlichkeit manifestieren als im
falle dessen dass sich dabei um ist so
etwas wie soziale gerechtigkeit oder
wissenschaftliche wahrheit oder eine
familientradition handelt als er spricht
jetzt sich aber durchaus eine emotionale
färbung und einer dringlichkeit was du
jetzt auf eine gefühlsmäßige aktie
dimension hinweist er zeigt aber
zugleich die liebe muss nicht immer nur
auf eine person gerichtet sein sondern
sie kann sie auf ganz verschiedene dinge
intentional richten wie eben ein land
eine institution das sind ja sehr
abstrakte objekte wie auch ein ideal und
so weiter
liebe ist unaufschiebbar eine
angelegenheit persönliche verhältnis es
gibt keine notwendigen beiden oder ab
rio vision prinzipien ich welche
festgestellt werden kann was wir liegen
sollen
und zwar jetzt im unterschied zu kants
theorie der achtung wo wir ganz klar
wissen nachdem was wir achten sollen
dass können wir nach kant objektiv
begründen so aber nicht bei der liebe
die zwänge welchen die liebenzeller das
relikt binden nicht auch unbefangen
gleichgültig liegen haben dann daran
andererseits der team begebung verlieben
der angebote oftmals im stritten sinne
unbedingt die unpersönliche mandate
pflicht können auch die imperative der
regel völlig kompromisslos sein und
schlupflöcher versagen und
ausflugsmöglichkeiten verweigern die
ansprüche die uns die liebe unsere
kinder oder unsere länder oder unsere
ideale stellen würden genauso
unmissverständlich kategorisch sein wie
jene die uns durch dessen roman schild
ist auffällig sind die vielen beider
arten ist kein raum für verhandlungen
wir dürfen unsere moralischen pflichten
einfach nicht verletzen und wir dürfen
das was wir lieben einfach nicht
verraten
also hier seid gezeigt wird gibt es eine
gewisse analogie zwischen moralität und
liebe sie haben eine verbindlichkeit
gewisse verpflichtung das ist das was er
dann auch eine tasse tee nennt franz
prenner entspricht denn man darf jetzt
aber nicht so weit gehen und denken dass
diese zwänge die mit der liebe nach werk
wird einhergehen dass die uns um frei
machen dass die uns also gewissermaßen
nötigen zu etwas was für eigentlich gar
nicht wollen
im gegensatz in der liebe drückt sich
gerade das aus was wir ursprünglich
wollen also da zeigt sich eine form von
autonomie und nicht von hetero- oder
beschränkung meiner meinung nach sei
gefragt wird weiter können handlungen
autonom sein was hier geht es jetzt um
die freiheit werden sie aus liebe getan
werden ob sie nun in übereinstimmung mit
der pflicht stehen dann nicht kann
zufolge hebt uns unser vermögen
moralische verpflichtung zu erkennen und
akzeptieren über die vernunft losen
tiere wenn das schreiben uns aber von
diesen tieren auf
der tatsache dass sie denn die beruflich
sieht wenn vernunft auf all das bezug
nimmt
was das charakteristische mensch nicht
macht dann sollten wir sie nicht einfach
als ein vermögen verstehen dass
ausschließlich darin besteht gründe zu
begreifen und regeln anzuwenden
sie muss auch unsere fähigkeit
beinhalten einstellungen gegenüber atmen
zum eigenen willen zu bilden statt
irgendeine diskursive oder schließende
tätigkeit ist es diese koalition aale
selbstreflexion die unseren vermögen der
liebe zu kommen
ok jetzt spricht er hier aber von einer
rationalen selbstreflexion das heißt er
holt jetzt doch wieder so was wie diese
kognitive funktion nein in seinem
begriff der liebe auch wenn er ihn von
der vernunft um die an schlüsseln und
regeln dann abgrenzt wie sie kann eben
konzipiert hat interessant ist jetzt
auch die frage im event ihre der liebe
unfähig sind wie auch tiere nach kant
der moralität unfähig sind das ist eine
frage die wir noch genauer diskutieren
müssen
also liebe scheint etwas mit unserer
vernünftige bildung durchaus dazu zu
haben auch wenn sie darin nicht aufgeht
in rain vernünftigen aktien wie
diskursive und erschließende tätigkeiten
also schlüsse zu ziehen oder zuordnung
mit ihm an das hat nach der liebe nichts
zu tun
obwohl sie nur bei höher entwickelten
tieren wie wir menschen sie sind
auftritte in vier fällen ist im grunde
passiv sie ist passiv bin der lebende
durch die abfahrt um motiviert ist dass
das erlangen oder der fortlaufende bis
jetzt des gegenstands seine liebe im
zuträglich sein wird es ist möglich dass
die erwartung ihm nicht wirklich bewusst
ist
sie muss sicherlich nicht aus
irgendeiner überlegten kalkulation oder
ein stadt zu resultieren dass die ein
oder andere weise jedoch beeindruckte
gegenstand den
denn als etwas das die eigenschaft
besitzt ihm zufrieden zu stellen oder zu
erfreuen
wo die miteinander
wünschenswerten zustand zu verschaffen
das ist die wirkliche grundlage von der
seine liebe des gegenstands abhängt
hängt davon ab dass er seinen geliebten
gegenstand einer eigenschaft zu spät die
seine lebenslagen verbessert weil sie
ein hauptsächlich an das objekt befindet
aber bereit ist dies an zu kennen oder
nicht tatsache dass es sich mit seinem
eigenen wollen beschäftigt also hier
zeigt er jetzt dass die liebe nicht aus
einer überlegten kalkulation oder
einschätzung resultieren muss ja das hat
nichts mit der vernunft im strengen sinn
zu tun ist aber auch nicht bloß
willkürliches oder etwas effektiveres so
weit geht er jetzt auch nicht also liebe
hat eine mittelstellung zwischen klose
effekt hat und der abstrakten vernunft
und zwar deswegen weil es genau der
wille ist da hat sich betrifft die
gebote selbstlose liebe aber sind
keinesfalls kategorisch die forderung
die uns durch unsere ideale unsere
kinder oder alters pro verlegt werden
dass die sonst uneigennützig und ohne
für außer zugeben mögen sind so
bedingungslos und unnachgiebig wie die
der moral liebe sz zuständig eine
kontingente angelegenheit anders als die
die taten des rheins werden die der
liebe nicht durch nationale
notwendigkeit gestützt die tatsache dass
liebe und ihre gebote logisch gesehen
beliebig sind bedeutet jedoch nicht dass
sie nach belieben preisgegeben oder
unwirksam
ein leben in anziehung der entscheidung
geben sollen oder was liebe uns
abverlangen soll steht uns sicherlich
nicht ganz interessant jetzt hier
spricht von geboten selbstloser liegen
als selbstlose nebels ihn an sich ist
wieder die caritas nicht die kopie dass
das ist die dass klose tieren nach
augustinus unter einer arbeitshöhe die
caritas die selbstlose ohne eigene zu
gehen liebe auch wenn diese liebe jetzt
nach friend wird immer auch so was
beinhaltet was uns zu etwas hinzieht wo
wir uns wohl fühlen
aber sie ist nicht nur auf der sechs
bezogen
es gibt gebote der liebe die aber nicht
mit den moralischen geboten zu
verwechseln sind obwohl sie auch wie die
moralischen quote kategorisch als er
spricht so etwas wie einem kategorischen
imperativ der liebe und nicht einem
kategorischen imperativ der fernsten
bekannten forderungen der liebe und die
sind uneigennützig bedingungslos und
unnachgiebig unser video
im gegensatz jetzt aber zum lokal wie
sie kann versteht ist liebe nicht
notwendig ist erinnert sich einen
kategorischen imperativ man kann das
alles absolut herleiten unsere pflicht
aus der reihe von vernunft im gegensatz
dieser notwendigkeit diese logische
notwendigkeit des kategorischen
imperativ betont jetzt frankfurt das
leben eine kontingente nicht nur wenn
die angelegenheit ist
sie hat nichts mit dem reinen
vernünftigen willen zu tun sie ist nicht
durch eine rationale neben notwendigkeit
gestützt wie der kategorische imperativ
ist also logisch gesehen beliebig das
ist konsequent
aber sie sind dennoch nicht nach dem
preis zu geben sondern sie würden uns
eine gewisse verpflichtung auf und jetzt
war man am ende noch sehen wie wir diese
verpflichtung genau zu verstehen haben
die imposanten stau auch immer die
motivation aale macht welche die
leidenschaft mobilisiert sein mag die
leidenschaften selber haben keine rente
motivation ahlen autorität
tatsächlich stehen die leidenschaften
kann uns überhaupt keine forderungen an
sich betrachtet abgesehen von
irgendwelcher zusätzlichen triebkraft
oder unterstützung die wir selbst indem
wir auf sie eingehen lee vermögen ist
ihre wirksamkeit uns zubewegen geht es
nicht eine angelegenheit
loser oder macht es gibt da nichts was
anderes wäre als eine stärke dieser
macht die von uns verlangt oder sogar zu
retten ihnen folgen zu handeln liebe
unterscheidet sich davon in diesen
großen leidenschaften man könnte auch
sagen effekte die tatsache dass eine
person etwas nicht liefert er nicht nur
elementares rohmaterial in dem sich
umgehen kann liebe ist keine elementare
psychische gegebenheit die selbst keine
besondere bewertende oder praktische
einstellungs seitens des liebhabers
gänzlich ihre mutter nationalen titels
und beinhaltet sicherlich keine person
dauern das zu leben was sich liebt sie
mag versucht haben zu vermeiden es zu
nehmen und sie kann versuchen ihre liebe
auszulöschen
zweifellos gibt es viele möglichkeiten
wo nationaler komplexität und
zwiespältigkeit aber lieber selbst ein
aspekt des willens ist kann es nicht
stimmen dass die liebe einer person die
etwas wirklich aufrichtig liebt völlig
unfreiwillig ist ja also die liebe ist
immer mit einer gewissen form von
freiheit verbunden
das sollte uns für die heutige sitzung
gewesen sein ich verabschiede mich bei
den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern und
freue mich auf die nächste sitzung